[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis franc kim je suis
instructeur de sel défense depuis 2009
et je vous enseigner des méthodes
simples pour vous sortir de situations
de conflits jeu sera assisté par noël
[Musique]
donc là imaginons que l'individu en gaz
une frappe destinées à atteindre les
membres supérieurs désaxé prenez le
contrôle du poignet l'entraîné au sol
[Musique]
donc là imaginons que l'individu vous
attaquent par derrière du trait et votre
confiance vous neutraliser le droit d'
attaque 2000 tours pour faire face donc
là imaginons que quelqu'un va emprunter
de l'argent vous a dit que vous le
rendra au bout d'une semaine pendant ça
fait 6 mois vous attendez votre pognon
ou passer des coups de fil et rien pas
de réponse et sous prétexte que votre
beau-frère faudrait dire à chaque mois à
quoi bon frag [ __ ] mais pour ce match
là ou quoi que ce soit à la maison tu
veux c'est toi mon frère l'écouta merde
bref toi
[Musique]
donc là toujours votre beau frère soit
disant oh le pauvre il n'a pas d'argent
vous allez sur son facebook le mec s'est
acheté la playstation sans argent le mec
s'est acheté la playsation ce que vous
faites vous les mettez une claque le
meds a même pas ta [ __ ] de donc là
imaginons qu'un individu est parti il a
foutu le camp et plus donc l'important
c'est d'être bien sur ses appuis et
surtout d'avoir deux copains qui veulent
attendre la sortie du dojo pour vous la
ramenez
j'étais en conflit donc là imaginez que
votre beau frère a porté plainte pour
coups et blessures questionnez vous
monsieur retenue laissait pas
impressionner tu as bien tu filmes du
film pokémon sur la pêche jamais jamais
les mentions à peut-être justement
[Musique]